right worked I don't know why I wasn't
working alright hello everybody
so this month is this month has been
totally crazy I think most of you would
know anybody who's there right now we
only got three people here so uh I'll
Jameel wait until a few other people
come if they do I need to log into
patreon you know like the thing with
patreon is that if you if you change
computers then you can't log on and you
have to like check an email and you have
to to to say that it's you but the
problem is it always takes him like 15
minutes before they before they they
send you the link and so I totally
forgot that and I had to I had to like
restart my computer today I had to
reinstall windows and everything one of
those days and and now I'm waiting for
the patreon email to come so that I can
see the questions alright so um I think
that so what I'm gonna do is since since
I'm waiting for this email to come
anyways I wanted to talk about publicly
about this whole patreon situation that
everybody has seen that everybody has
seen going on so I'm gonna tell this
story I think most people will know the
story I'm gonna tell it just so that
whoever it is that is going to see this
on on patreon or on the other on
unsubscribe star will know exactly all
that stuff that happened okay some of
you heard the story before because
you've been following the whole thing
but I'm gonna tell it anyways just so
that everybody gets gets a sense of
what's going on
so patreon last year I think I think it
was last year they banned a few people
they banned what's her name haha I think
they I forget her name
Laura southern so they ban Laura
southern who is a right-leaning
journalist who worked for rebel media
and I think they also bad faith Goldy
and maybe a few other people boys
it was mostly lower southern that was
banned and it made some waves some
people were a bit annoyed by what they
did but it was a bit it was a bit gray
area because Laura southern did post
some videos where she's definitely you
know wearing you know helmet and she
she's involved in the indy
demonstrations so so it was a bit shaky
and then so people were frustrated but
they didn't do anything about it and now
this time they banned first off they
banned Milo like one day after he signed
up and then they banned sargon of akkad
and and then I think it was mostly the
Sargon thing that just got people very
really fuming because Sargon posted a
video right after being banned he posted
a video about what happened and it was
extremely frustrating for those who
don't know the story so patreon sent he
woke up one morning and then he went to
his computer and he saw they had like
10,000 emails and he was rendering and
he saw all these emails were telling him
that his patreon had been suspended so
and you had no email from patron so he
goes on to his wit on to our patreon and
there there it is it just says this this
website this page doesn't exist anymore
so he had to write them and they had to
wait several hours and they finally sent
him an email to tell him why they in
banned him and they told him that they
abandoned because he had used racial
slur to insult somebody and they told
him that it was on YouTube and it was
this day this date on this this feed and
so there are several problems with that
the first problem was that was that job
jack conte had been on Ruben report and
had said that people would not be bad
would not be banned for the way that
they acted on other social media
platform they would be banned only on on
patreon what it is it been put up on
patreon and he then he also said that
people would not be banned for the
political opinion but would be been only
for what he called
what is it manifest observable behavior
which which ironically very strangely
spells mo B mob so so that's what that
was the reason why people would be bad
so now we have this first problem is
that this didn't happen either on
Sargon's channel nor did it happen on
patreon but it happened on some other
small channel I think that had like 4000
subscribers and that's where he used
that racial slur second of all the
context in which he used the racial slur
was that he was speaking to two extreme
right you know kind of outright type
people and what he was doing is he used
the he said you guys are white you know
n-word whatever and and he did it in a
way to to flip it on them he said you
know the way that you're you're saying
that blacks are the way that you're
you're saying the way blacks act that's
the way you're acting so he was trying
to flip the whole script on them use
words that they hate to insult them and
also to say to kind of flip the the the
racist racist card back on them and so I
mean you can disagree with what he did
you could find that it's too extreme
that it's let's say that it might not be
the best strategy to use and that it
might be too offensive sure you could
agree but it was still not it was still
not done in a way that was let's say a
it was a way to flip racism against
itself so the context was really
important in what he said so that's the
second part and so the fact that they
banned him that they banned him from
patron which is means that they removed
his livelihood patreon basically manages
people's livelihoods when you go on
patreon you are giving you are giving
them the mandate to manage your money
you're giving them the mandate to manage
to manage the relationships between the
people who like what you're doing and
are giving money as well as and yourself
and so that's the trust that we have in
patreon and so and now patreon is
banning him for that that specific
reason
now people were extremely upset and then
since then also people have been showing
that there are plenty of places on
patreon where that word where the N word
is used as a racial slur that there are
podcasts on page rounded use those types
of words there are other other people on
patreon that have as crazy a thing as
raising money to commit suicide people
who raise money to to overthrow the
government you know all kinds of crazy
thing and tifa's on patreon and so the
fact that that Sargon was targeted was
obviously because there was someone
there who didn't like him you know maybe
someone who is who is already coming out
of gamergate who was was in that crew
that crowd and so and so then what
happened is that it was kind of like the
straw the the final straw and and people
just started bailing from patreon and so
I saw and so what happened is on my
patreon I was really annoyed it I was
very frustrated I I saw that Sargon went
to this new website called subscribe
start so I said alright I'll go to
subscribe so I'll set up subscribe scar
and then I'll slowly inform people on
patreon to move platform and so I go to
subscribe star and then the people who
are more active on social media maybe
follow me on twitter follow me on on
Facebook I forget how many people moved
let's see so what so not that many
people move like the 30 people moved
okay
so 30 people left patreon went
unsubscribe star and I'm like okay we're
gonna do this progressively get
everybody to go but then within like two
days
subscribe star stop giving out PayPal
payments and so that means that for me
for example I'm in I'm in Canada and so
that means that I need to get an
international bank wire bank transfer in
American funds and I so I need to figure
out how to get that into too I mean they
probably could help to do it they'd get
that into my account so first of all
that's really expensive to do that
transfer second of all it was very
suspicious that just a few days after
this happened all of a sudden PayPal
pulls out of
scribe start then the day after
subscribes to our stop taking
subscribers and stop taking payments and
so that's it so it's like it's frozen
and so so many people jumped from
patreon to subscribe star and now
subscribe stars frozen and so we have
this this this exile from patreon you
know I lost I would say I lost about
maybe fifteen twenty percent of the of
the the donations on patreon and then I
was able to obviously to catch some of
those people on on subscribes are but I
would I caught less than half let's say
of the people moving out of patreon
because yeah subscribes are basically
stopped and so no people didn't some
people weren't able to make it or some
people you know just we're just
frustrated and ever transition and so
that's where we are now it's very very
frustrating you know that this situation
is is happening and so and so now so
what happened so the next thing that
happened is that during peterson and
dave rubin went online and said that
they would develop a platform in order
to be a competitor to patreon and so
some people got excited about that i
have to be totally honest with you i did
not get that excited about that and so I
wrote Jordan right away and I said I say
Jordan I I understand that you want to
put up this platform you know I you know
I I trust you for sure I trust you but I
don't think it's you I think it's the
financial institutions and so even if
you do set up a competitor what do you
do if if if PayPal and the others won't
help you make those financial
transactions and so Jordan answered me
and said that that he might not be able
to get PayPal but he said for sure
stripe would would support them and so I
don't know like I don't know who he's in
contact with obviously Jordan has some
some very high contacts with with I mean
strangely enough they the the IDW has
contacts with Peter Thiel who's the CEO
of a PayPal I mean Eric Weinstein worked
for Peter Thiel for quite a long time
and so I don't all of this is very
just very weird and I don't know what's
gonna happen so so now what I'm doing is
is I'm working with the people who set
up my website a nominalist anomalous
design they have been just amazing in
general in terms of helping me out and
kind of working with me being very very
flexible and also extremely attentive to
what I need and so they're working
really fast to set up a payment system
directly on my website so that I can
take payments on the website it'll
probably be through PayPal as well but I
mean PayPal is not gonna come after me
obviously you know obviously although in
the long run if this keeps going at some
point I could be affected directly in
terms of the content that I'm producing
I have said some things that are
obviously not totally in line with the
political correct line but I'm also not
provocateur and so I don't think that
it's going to happen anytime soon
um and so so I'm waiting for them to set
that up they'll probably be to PayPal
and through hopefully through credit
card payment people can keep supporting
me directly on the website so that way
things are gonna be safe then I can put
up the tiered content directly onto the
website and people who want to go to
will have the Q&A is there and if I do
other type of like the the pre the the
early access to videos will be also on
directly on my website so so yeah so
that's the situation you know today I
saw Jordan posted a tweet he tweeted
that he you know that this is
complicated and it's gonna take a long
time and so he set up on his website an
easy way to donate directly on his
website so I think we need to take that
as a sign that that it's creating the
competitor to patreon in a world where
the tech companies are are trying to
shut down free speech I think that it's
not going to be easy in you know in
several ways sargon of akkad on his
video where he talked about this this D
platforming that he got he played a
speech by the CEO of Apple and the CEO
of Apple I've been invited to the
abl the anti-defamation league to give a
speech and the speech that he gives is
absolutely insane
you would you think you would think that
you were in church and you were
listening to a preacher and so the the
CEO of Apple started talking about how
it's our responsibility to remove this
hate speech from online it's our
responsibility to remove the harmful
conspiracy theories from from the online
space and he said we can do it and if we
didn't do it it would be a sin he
literally uses the word sin to speak
about their the text company's
responsibility to manage the content
online and it all is you know it's all
it's all framed in beautiful language in
virtuous language and everything but in
the end what ends up happening is is a
centrist who is a classical liberal
provocateur who doesn't like you know he
doesn't like third wave feminism and and
social justice warriors guess D platform
from patriarchy that's that's the final
result of what he said and also certain
Christian groups certain certain more
traditional groups are who advocate for
traditional values are already being
purged from the internet as we speak we
you know i i've been told about certain
groups for example certain groups that
that encourage traditional family who
also want to to talk about talk about
people who had you know alternative
lifestyles who then find a more
traditional lifestyle and and how they
they were able to be transformed to
follow those traditional lifestyles
those channels are being purged just
basically erased from from the online
space and so they're there's all kinds
of things going on so so that's the
situation with that let me just see so i
have not yet gotten that patreon that
patreon all right how about this I'm
gonna I'm gonna read I think there were
a few subscribe star
questions alright so so Jacob asks just
is this Jacob Russell I don't know
because I don't know the subscribes are
people I don't they don't use real names
so I don't even know who it is
yeah it's a good idea it's a good idea
you guys if you guys want we might you
might be able to let me answer these two
patreon quickly the let's let me answer
these to subscribe to our questions and
and and once we're done if I didn't get
this this patreon email yet you can just
ask questions here in the chat as well
because we don't have that many people
in the chat kind of figured we'd have
less people in the chat we're getting
close to you're getting close to
Christmas so people are busy all right
so so Jacob asks all right so Jake it is
Jacob Russell all right Jacob asks can
you describe the meaning of a blessing
and a curse I'm thinking specifically
about Isaac blessing Jacob Jacob instead
of Esau but I'm also trying to wrap my
mind around something like a blessing
from a priest okay so the notion I mean
the notion of the blessing okay has to
do with first of all it's analogous lee
analogically related to the idea of the
logos in the beginning of time that
creates the world so that's what its
analogically related to the the blessing
is like a lower version of that and it
it has to do with the idea of how human
beings participate in the way that the
world lays them lays itself up and they
participate in a manner which is let's
say them the holier you are you could
say or it could also be the more
powerful you are let's say in a negative
sense the more that you are capable of
affecting the world through your
speech through the way that you you
speak it it's not just affecting but
it's like affecting and participating in
the world there's a there is a scene in
the matrix which I which I've always
liked and it's the end it's the scene
where the Oracle is is saying things I
don't forget what it is and then she
tells him don't worry about the vase and
he says would vase he turns around he
hits the vase the vase breaks and she
says that vase and then and then she
says something like what's really gonna
start messing with your mind is if you
ask yourself you know if it would have
happened if I didn't tell you that it
that it was going to happen so that
starts to mess with your mind so that
the idea is the the the relation in a
blessing the relationship of causality
of someone whose blessing it's difficult
to totally understand in the sense that
it's in a way it's both a causing and a
participation in the way that things are
because the person who is capable of
blessing is is acting as a principal as
a present principality remember I told
you about the principality and so the
father the priest the king the authority
or the spiritual authority like a
prophet someone who has spiritual
authority or it could be temporal
Authority as well or it could be
familial Authority that person is by
being the principle of a group of people
then that that person can have an effect
on the way that that group is going to
lay itself out but if it's properly done
that that effect is also in line with
the way things should be so there it's
not like there's a contradiction between
the way that things will unfold and the
way and the fact that someone speaks it
into being that's going to be really
hard for people to understand it's it's
the
also the problem of the way that people
understand agency and understand freedom
um you know people who have this idea
that God could have created the world in
any way that he wanted to it's like no
God couldn't have created the way any
other way any way that he wanted to God
created the world out of his own being
and that world is the world and so the
world is the reflection of God and and
God's will is in the world and then
things lay themselves out so the laying
the laying of itself out in the
causality of the world that is the
mirror of God and it is the the way that
the world you can find God in the way
that the world lays itself out and
there's no it doesn't mean that you
abstract the causality that's there so
the idea of a blessing of someone let's
say speaking of blessing on their on
their child or on their on their wife or
you know or a priest blessing a person
when it's effective you know especially
when the priest is a holy person
especially when the the prophet is is
connected connected to reality connected
to God then then those two things the
speaking into reality and the unfolding
of reality are like the same thing
they're they think they're they go
together I don't know if this is making
sense you guys cuz I think that I think
that this might be a little bit a little
bit I might be pushing a little bit
further than what I push you until now
with this type of thinking so this might
be this might this might be something
that is a little difficult to understand
hopefully that hopefully that's good
enough for now at least
alright
okay so Jacob also asks using the terms
phrases and ideas you express in the
rebel wisdom interview as well as the
symbolic language you're known for
how would you articulate what the good
news is to recovering atheists well
hmm that's interesting i mean i think
that if i if i tried to speak let's say
and kind of say languages can be
understood by atheists or i post
atheists or recovering atheists you know
the good news is is I mean it's the same
good news that Christ said the good news
is is is the Incarnation its Christ in
the world its Christ in you its Christ
hit it in creation it's basically the
idea that the world is full of meaning
the world is brim full of of sparks of
light and that if you are aligned
properly if you are looking in the right
direction if you are if you are
worshiping the right God if you you know
if you if you are celebrating the right
thing then in that celebration in that
participation and you can participate in
the meaning of the world and you can be
you can be lit lit up by those sparks
that you encounter in all of all of
creation and so in more traditional
Christian language you know you would
say that we that we you know we we enter
into the life of Christ and then the
mystery that has been hidden from us
from the beginning of time which is
Christ and us Christ in the world it
begins to appear and we begin to
participate it in into it and so that to
me is the that's the good news that's
the good news of Christ that's when it's
always been and maybe that's a way to
for people to understand it in in a
language that is a little more akin to
what what I've been using before alright
guys this isn't happening
so either either we either we we get
some questions in here or I'm going to
I'm going to have to start riffing and
improvising something so if you guys
have questions there's only five people
here and then I already answered two of
Jacob's questions so if you guys have
questions
go ahead right now and then and then
I'll answer those first it could be the
question from patreon or it could be
another question as it stands now
because we're kind of in a strange
situation literally low only 200
characters you can put the questions in
to posts if you want that's totally fine
also it could help you not to end not to
ask complicated questions Jacob
hahaha go for it all right
Adam she lured oh you guys can access
you guys can access my patreon and I
can't that is hilarious
that is hilarious I didn't even think of
that all right all right let's do this
okay so Adam shall art ask you've said
Christianity has in itself the
instructions for its own revival can you
go more into that yes
it's yes I think that he had talked
about the fact that that Christianity
has in itself the story of its own
demise and so that's that's the first
important thing the idea that the
Christianity that you have to understand
the story of Christianity kind of
playing out the story of Christ you have
like the you know how symbolism is dizzy
embedded microcosms so you can imagine
the story of Christ start you know being
hidden hidden in the world and
manifesting itself until the Incarnation
where then it became it became incarnate
in one person and I think that then the
next step is for it to to kind of be
incarnate in bigger like bigger and
bigger on a continent more and more
cosmic scale and so in terms of in terms
of Christianity it means that in the
story of Christianity and if you read
revelations and if you read even the
prophecies of Christ there is this sense
that faith will we'll leave that the
world will get darker and things are
going to become more difficult and
there'll be tribulations and they'll be
you know all these things and oh Christ
says you know when I return will I fight
will I find faith in the world and so
when the Son of Man comes will he find
faith in the world so it's like when he
comes back will he find faith in the
world so so for sure when we see
Christianity dying and we see
Christianity kind of going away then we
we shouldn't be surprised in the sense
that out of cry out of the disciples out
of the Apostles came the Judas and came
the the day the the turning away from
from Christ but also st. Peter also the
the denial of Christ came out of out of
out of Christianity so you have you have
a st. Peter who denies Christ you have
Judas who betrays Christ and so those
two those two things were part of the
story and so the question is its way
wasn't
that atheism would come out of
Christianity that of all the religions
in the world that atheism and
anti-clerical anti-clericalism and just
anti religious thinking in itself would
emerge out of Christianity it was just
as part of the was part of the story
Antichrist is part of the story of
Christ but I think that I think that
that Antichrist can be kind of flip back
I think that you can turn things back
and so it seems to me that Christianity
also has in itself the story of a of a
return and so you know this whole image
of the return of Christ is there from
the from Christ talking about it himself
to the to the Book of Revelations we
have this notion that Christ will return
in glory and judge the living in the
dead and so I think that that's that's
also part of the story now in terms of
how it's going to happen I think that I
tried to lay it out I tried to lay it
out a few times in some discussions
recently I don't know totally how it's
going to to to happen I do think that I
can start to see glimpses of how it's
happening right now and I think that
that Jordan Peterson and all this this
kind of all this stuff that's been
happening has been part of this
reawakening of Christianity and I think
it kind of goes something like this
where you know that discussion that
Jordan had with Dave Rubin
and Ben Shapiro I talked about it on the
rebel wisdom video I think that that you
can see it happening there it's like
once you reach a fully you know
biological reduction like once you reach
a fully biological reduction what
happens is you can no longer ignore
certain parts of the world until now
what people have been doing is saying
you know okay we're going to reduce
everything to two to this by this
scientific level in this biological
level and we're going to do this in
opposition to religion we're gonna say
religion is stupid
which really smart is science science is
really smart and scientific reasoning
and biology and physics and all this is
they're really smart and really in
religion was just a really stupid thing
that happened you know and that we're
getting away from it's like okay but
once you've totally in theory gotten
away away from religion and you've
reduced everything to these material
causes you have to then explain religion
you can't just toss it because you want
everything to fit in the material sphere
you it has to where else you're missing
something and then when you try to take
religion and then you try to fully
explain it in terms of just material
causes then it flips it flips back
because you we're seeing it happen now
because all of a sudden Jordan Jordan
Peterson will say something like well
it's if there's the spirit of
masculinity that that that animates the
production of hierarchies and and the
fact that we choose certain males to be
at the head of social hierarchies and
then they end up having more power and
also can mate with more females and so
this thing happens and it grows and it
grows and then out of that biological
thing comes out a a figure of the ideal
male and then that figure gets projected
up into heaven and then that figure up
in heaven becomes something like the
Father Heavenly Father
okay and it's like okay you've done that
but then you all of that you have to
then it flips because it's like why is
all all that is happening because that's
a description of how reality works and
is that's how reality lays itself out
and so the pattern that the pattern of
masculinity which brought up
this image of God the Father that
pattern of masculinity is real and it's
an it's a it's an underlying structure
which which which manifest itself and
then it becomes and then and you can see
analogically then then that's one of the
underlying structures of all of reality
and so the fact that this image of God
the Father emerged is because this image
of God the Father is the best way to
understand how reality works is the best
way to to describe to to human beings
just how the whole thing works so so
well now you've taken it all back but
then what happens is it flips and then
all of a sudden things start to come out
you know that the religious perception
all of a sudden starts to manifest
itself again because you see that you
see you see it happening I don't know if
that makes sense
I hope it makes sense let me see what
you guys are saying about this all right
you guys I got the email so I just got
it now so you don't have to be pasting
these these here anymore all right
okay so I've so we're here I've got it I
let do with this thing
all right oh so those were okay so
you're just posted question all right
you guys don't have to post questions
anymore let me just get back to this to
here sorry about the confusion guys all
right he would go all right
December QA question for December Q&A
all right okay all right I think I got
them all all right okay here we go
sorry so it's hard for the K out guys
so Jeremy Furth says I grew up Mormon
went through the Mormon temple this is a
really long question okay so how do I
explain to my friends and family in a
succinct way that I believe in religion
but I don't think heaven is a literal
place seems very nuanced and that I'm
playing word tricks to an onlooker I'm
having a hard time articulating that
obviously Santa Claus is real
obviously Santa Claus exists in a way
that makes sense and doesn't make me
sound crazy
any advice man I'm gonna I'm gonna say
that it's tough I think it's tough that
if you're trying to explain it to
Mormons I think it's really tough
because because morons do believe in
that God I mean I don't know this is
this I'm not a Mormon but what I
understand a Mormon teaching is that
Mormons do actually think that God is on
an it's like on another planet or that
something like that or that when you die
you go to this planet in in the cosmos
and
you're kind of on this planet and then
you can also create you can become a god
and then you can create a world and then
those people are gonna go on on planets
and so so it's very very it seems very
materialistic at least in my perception
I don't know if that's if that's totally
a good understanding of it but I think
that the only way I think to to help
people understand that heaven isn't a
literal place in the sense that it's a
it's a place like a like your house I
mean like I said it's gonna be tough if
you're talking in the Mormons I mean I
always ask people because people will
say things crazy things like people will
say you know Christ Christ okay so
here's a good way here's a good way
here's a good way now they'll be one who
uses the word spiritual okay and so
maybe try to get people to explain to
you what they mean by my spiritual
because usually people will say
something like spiritual is non non
material things or something that's not
material okay
and so maybe try to get them to talk a
little bit about what that means like
what it is what it's what is spiritual
and so once you start to kind of talk
about what something spiritual is
meaning that it's not physical then you
can try to say something like well you
know the word spiritual it just means
wind
it just means breath and so what you're
talking about these spiritual things do
you do you think that that they're in
your physical breath do you think that
like when I when I blow on someone that
I am that that that's what he means by
spiritual something
and most people will say obviously no
and then you can try to help them
understand well it's because when you
blow when you that's also speaking
speaking is air that's what it is
speaking is an exchange of spirit
because I'm I'm talking to you and I'm
not causing any physical change I'm not
feeding you I'm not giving you something
I'm speaking
but I'm affecting the world I'm
affecting you your mind I'm affecting
our relationship by speech that's
spiritual that that is why we talk about
spirituality being the way it is and so
heaven is the same this is for the same
in the same way that that you don't
think that spiritual just means my
breath or it just means wind blowing in
the same way heaven is is a word that's
used to to because air is in heaven
spirits wind is in heaven just like wind
comes out of your mouth wind is also in
heaven and so it's all these images to
help you talk about things that are not
material and you can't talk about things
that are not material because they're
not material you have to use analogies
to talk about them so I think that
that's probably the maybe the best way
to to to help people understand at least
this idea of heaven as not being a
literal place and also the idea of the
necessity of analogy to speak about
spiritual things and it doesn't mean
that it's arbitrary most people will say
oh well then it's arbitrary they just be
anything but it's not no it's a it's a
very specific very structured way of
speaking that is perfectly coherent
which tries to talk about things that
are that are invisible things that are
related to meaning to identity to you
know to to to the hidden things in the
world which makes them you know come
together and makes them exist and so
that's what that's what that's what
spirituality is and that's also what
heaven refers to so I I don't know if
that if that helps
Jeremie not sure but hopefully it does
alright is it quarter to ten already
how's that even possible
yeah all right we're gonna go longer
tonight just because just because it's
just because it's been my own fault that
everything has been nutty okay alright
so Frank Raleigh asks without
elaboration ten examples of garments of
skins
luckily gives me two already says
clothes technology etc alright without
elaboration okay let's do ten okay so
grants kit so clothes technology prom
with technologies and it's very very
wide but let's add one let's say
medicine okay
you could also say our desires have also
become part of our our garments of skin
weapons what we called a Potro pay ik
images a portal page images are the idea
of using something fearful to scare
something else away so everything from
Batman to gargoyles to you know the the
you know the Romans also had like
monsters on the outside of their houses
kind of monster type creatures to just
scare things away I mean obviously this
might be cheating but but civilization
itself you know
cities houses all the things that we
build to protect ourselves from the from
the from the outside world and so a
soldier himself you know can also be
part of the of the garments of skin in
the sense of the soldier standing on on
a wall like a shield you can imagine the
shield as being an image of garments of
skin and then
then there are stranger aspects of the
garments of skin and I'll save those two
for the last they're parts of the
garments of skin are also in version
okay and also I would say mockery I put
those two there you said without you
said without collaboration so I'm not
gonna explain them all right okay all
right some of these aren't questions
okay so let's go
okay so Jeffrey Muller asks oftentimes I
catch myself speaking in a way my
friends don't always understand I've
noticed this is when I mention a word
when I mean it symbolic meaning not it's
literal they seem to understand it in an
abstract way but it's almost as if
symbolism as a deeper layer of
complexity to our language if we were to
call this symbolic language what is
everyone else speaking I think you're
right I think I think that the the
difference between symbolic language and
the language that is used by modernity
and also the and this is the guys you're
going to struggle with this as you start
to discover some odd language I would
say that I've spent you know a large
part of my life trying to find a way to
talk about this so that people wouldn't
mistake what I'm saying sorry
most people do
you think that let's say symbolically
when you talked about this this problem
of the metaphor the idea that people
think that metaphors only only refer to
abstract more abstract things let's say
are that we moving from moving into from
reality or concrete reality to
abstraction that's the way to move let's
say that's the way to to go and so
whereas in in symbolism what happens is
rather a kind of diving in and a
noticing of of the analogy and so when
we use a word in symbolism to refer to
something which is invisible we're using
it analogically that is it's not it's
not just a code it's not just arbitrary
and it's not it's not just referring to
something which is which is more
abstract but it's it's it's almost as if
it's an instantiation of the thing we're
we're pointing to it's an actual
instantiation and that's how symbolism
works and so for example if I talk about
let's say a tree as a symbol of order
okay a symbol of of an of ordering
principle or a symbol of the the manner
in which the world is ordered in
microcosm right in a in a pattern of
fractals and so all you say I use the
tree but the tree is an instantiation of
that that is it's not it's not arbitrary
it's not just a fun metaphor it's not
just something something witty you know
or some are some interesting image that
I use to represent something know the
tree is an instantiation of that
structure so it is an actual fractal and
it and it's ending and so to use that as
a as a as an image to help you
understand
you know the deeper reality it's because
it's an instantiation of it and so and
so that's just kind of how that's how
that's how symbolism work you kind of
dive in and so you you you start to see
how the world is connected the modern
language we have today the analytic
language is always to show difference
between things it's always to
distinguish things from each other
catalog them classify them know we love
dictionaries and and we love you know
like classification systems whereas the
symbolic language is rather trying to
show how things are coming together and
showing us deeper and deeper and deeper
patterns as we see how they're connected
and so it's it's it's difficult you're
going to struggle as you understand
symbolism but like I said you have to be
able at least for a while you have to be
able to exist in the two worlds you
can't you can't lose connection to the
to the kind of materialistic basic world
you have to be careful because if you do
that you're going to you're going to
look absolutely insane and people gonna
think you're crazy
and they might be right to think that
you're crazy so you have to be able to
to continue you know like I've told you
guys several times I usually don't talk
about this stuff you know in in everyday
life because because I know people don't
understand and I'm and if I say certain
things I'm gonna sound crazy like with
some of you guys I'm sure that some of
you follow me carefully
there are some things that I that you
may have heard me say let's say the
first time you heard some of my videos
which just totally fall went right over
her head it's like you didn't hear it it
didn't even register or you were just
like what is he saying like why are you
saying that and then going back and and
listen listening to them maybe now you
know like after a year after several
months of listening to some of my stuff
you're like okay yeah that's what he
said that that's why that's why he and
so it's like it's it so you have to
understand that it's it's it's very it's
really difficult to talk about this
stuff so so yeah so Geoffrey I'm sorry
that you're suffering from this all
right
so so Gavin Dottie asks in last month's
Q&A you said if I can paraphrase that in
everyday life our esoteric language
often has to break down to make way for
simple language out that just talking
about that ha ha for simple language
that accommodates our experience of the
mundane and those with less education
but you obviously still believe in
transmitting the faith to as it were
simple people in a profound and complex
way or you wouldn't love the liturgy so
if in general you believe in this sort
of accommodation within the church why
not why not for the liturgy okay so this
is the thing this is the difference
between there's a difference between
enacting symbolism and explaining
symbolism those two things are very
different so you can watch of you can
watch a movie you can watch a Marvel
movie or you can read a Batman comic
book and you can be completely absorbed
by the structure in it because it is the
structure of it is coming close to the
structure of reality so you feel
completely like enlivened by the
structure you feel completely pulled in
to this structure and but you don't have
to understand it you don't have to to be
able to analyze why it's doing what it's
doing and so that's why liturgy and
that's why in a traditional world most
people would never explain symbolism the
way I'm doing the reason why I need to
explain symbolism is because we've gone
so far away from a normal way of
engaging with the world it's almost like
what I'm doing is is you know might be
something of a scandal the fact that I
that I'm explaining this stuff normally
we in a normal world we would just be
participating in it and then you would
receive your intuition that's a level
that you can that you can kind of
receive them so so the so the liturgy is
very different because it isn't an
explaining of the symbolism it's a
participation in them you know it's a
it's one step
from watching a movie from listening to
music because you're in the pattern
you're actually participating you're
your part of the cosmic dance you could
say and so it's very different than
explaining you don't have to explain
that to people you the the people that
I'm talking to most of the people I'm
talking to are people who are are smart
are educated and because of that
smartness and education they felt like
they've been left behind by by
Christianity and also because there has
been you know a horrible slew of silly
materialists who have been trying to to
defend Christianity in those terms for a
while now and so it's very alienating to
people so I'm trying to give those
people the people who have been
alienated by Christianity with good
reason to say no like let's look back at
it now and I know and I'll try to give
you a frame at which at your level you
can see it you know and just those the
other people the people who are are
stuck in their in their frame it's like
don't just just don't listen to them or
don't engage them even because there's
no point in convincing someone who there
are some people who will never
understand symbolism ever they will
never the light will not go on they just
won't click it's debt and that's totally
fine you know yeah I mean becomes a
problem they tried to destroy
traditional Christianity which we've
seen the modern age there's kind of
hatred of liturgy and the hatred of
anything that is that is symbolic you
know you know has been quite a shame you
wish that you would sit at least some
people in the church would have had the
the intuition to to understand these
things at that time so yeah it's a sad
thing all right ok so david Flores asked
what icon painters in your opinion
managed to merge modern elements with
the traditional in a way that is
successful I recently stumbled across
the work of Greta Lesko and SIA tus
lovely dica I don't know how much about
either of them are just a handful of
icons ok
and was surprised at how they have
integrated modern elements into the
icons I was not aware work was being
done like theirs okay so there are
several there are several artists right
now several iconographies who are trying
to integrate traditional traditional
work with contemporary art and so the
way you have to see it to me the way you
have to see it is you kind of have to
see it in a in a way it's a danger it's
a danger because there's a lot of
individualism and that there's a lot of
like my own style and my own my own work
which i think is problematic in the long
run it's becomes problematic if most
people are doing it okay if there's an
exception of people who are innovating
let's say or trying new things and kind
of pushing things look further trying to
integrate things from the contemporary
art then that let's say that you can
imagine that part of being on the
periphery you know like imagine the
church and that parts on the periphery
they're kind of playing they're kind of
taking in things from the outside you
know mushing them around it's like a
laboratory and then you know people who
are kind of standing more on the inside
towards let's say towards the towards
the more traditional work can look at
that and go yeah ya know ya know this
stuff that's too much there's oh this is
interesting
and then things will start to filter in
which will be let's say maybe less
extreme more more toned down you know
and we'll be able to integrate the
visible the visual the visual language
of the church and so I think that that's
possible now it's difficult because we
live in a world that is so obsessed with
innovation and it's so obsessed with
personal style and kind of personal
career ism that I tend to be more
suspicious to people who radically try
to integrate postmodern ideas or I image
an imagery from modern art into their
work but I think that today for today
there are people who do it quite
successfully
I think that father Gregory Krug who's
quite famous is someone who did it in a
very in a way that created work that
that remained extremely predict very
traditional and also felt very
liturgical as well I think that there's
a there's a and iconographer in the
United States that I that I really
appreciate father silouan just in Yano I
think that he is doing exactly that he's
in he's bringing in some color ways of
looking at color ways of looking at
space you know that are very that I
think are very successful in his work
and then there are others who I think
are just going way too far and are just
trying to attract attention to
themselves and I think those I have a
high of around without with them
Jesse Blaney asked what is the
difference in the theology of Dreams and
prophecies in the Orthodox tradition
compared to Protestant also have certain
icons or stories be prophetically
receipt
the thing with Protestant vision of
theology or of dreams and prophecies is
that I don't when someone asked me like
what is the Protestant vision of of
dreams and and which which of the
thousands of denominations are you
talking about I don't know like I don't
know I think that I think that some some
Protestant strains like more reformed or
more Puritan tend to be quite opposed to
you know prophecies and dreams and
miracles and all that stuff whereas some
more some other groups you know like
Pentecostal type groups today they they
have no problem with that
in the Orthodox in the Orthodox
tradition I I think that there's no
problem with with the idea of dreams
that could have meaning or people
uttering prophecies or have you know you
know operating certain miracles that's
not at all a problem you know I think it
always has to
framed within the sanctity of the life
of someone and I think that that might
be the difference between some even the
Pentecostal type Pentecostal type vision
of it is that it's holy people who who
do that I guess holy people who under
prophecies and we'll also have miracles
or we'll have important dreams let's say
the whole year you are the more those
are clear and are worth trusting
and so that so you and so there's a
relationship between the transformation
of the person and the capacity to do
that and for sure the the the mystics
the Orthodox mystics tell people to
beware of those though to not rely on
them because they can be a seductive
thing if you start to have experience or
experiences start to to to see things
start to have kind of prophetic visions
or you you start to to be able to to
even heal people or do that kind of
stuff then it's very you can you can
think that you've made it that's that's
the point right that's the purpose and
be and be kind of pulled away from that
and so the the mystics actually tell be
able to just ignore that stuff to not to
not bother with it it's like oh you can
you have mystical visions you can see
prophetic things yeah just ignore that
stuff you can you can you know you can
do miracles and that's not the point you
know you keep moving keep moving don't
don't stop at that and so that might be
maybe the difference between between
Orthodox but there are plenty of stories
there plenty of stories of prophetically
received things in the in the Orthodox
Church there is for example a there is a
prayer the true Sagi on prayer in the
Orthodox faith that says holy God holy
mighty holy immortal have mercy on us
okay so that prayer is something we say
all the time see that prayer all the
time
and they're the tradition is that it was
a young boy in Constantinople was it in
the in the fourth century in the fifth
century who during the liturgy was taken
up into heaven you know had a mystical
experience with it during the liturgy
and then kind of announced this prayer
to the to the church you know and he
told the the church what he saw in his
in his experience and and right then and
there the church received that prayer
and it became part of the of the liturgy
and so I mean I don't know what it was I
don't know exactly what happened I don't
know it's hard to imagine that situation
you know happening today but it is part
of our tradition those types of events
are part of our tradition there are
there are other there are other moments
in them in the Orthodox tradition where
people or groups of people for example
in a church where the whole church has a
vision of the mother of God holding you
know the this holding a veil and
protecting Constantinople or for example
yeah there's a tradition of st. Nicholas
of Mosiah Square the entire town had a
vision of st. Nicholas who was holding a
sword and the church and and it was a it
was a sign that the church would be
would be protected from invaders and so
yeah all those things all those things
are can happen but the thing is they're
not that that's not the point
like that's not that's not what this is
about you know and we have to be careful
not to be too attached to those types of
events all right hope that helps
our Jacob asked
questionin City has to go soon all right
Jacob gets priority because he's he's
he's a she runs the Facebook group ha ha
ha all right I'm have to go soon so my
wife and I are very interested in
iconography now she's began painting a
few you mentioned somewhere about
iconology are there some good books
about this or talks I would say in terms
of iconology there are several resources
I always tell people to read the meaning
of icons I was having here this book
right here the meaning of icons by
vladimir lossky and lenny this penske
this is a great book this is definitely
everybody should everybody's interested
in icon should read that book ok I love
vladimir lossky as some people know you
can also go on the Orthodox art journal
which is free and you can read the I've
written several articles on iconology on
on that website there's also another
website which is amazing and it's called
icon reader and it's just it's an it's
an anonymous person who is basically
just goes through all the icons and and
just kind of explains what's in the icon
he just said these are the elements in
each icon you know here you just
explained them where they come from in
terms of if they refer to scripture or
if they recorded tradition and and how
it comes together so so that website is
is it is really a very valuable resource
and I would suggest people see it go
through it if you're interested in that
all right
so okay so Vladimir bout you bass you
asked you haven't to know what jbp is so
rarely seen in conversation with
scholars are educated and articulate
people of the Christian conviction which
you being with you being the delightful
exception I I don't totally understand
that it does in fact strangely seem to
be that I am one of Jordans only
Christian friend it seems somehow and he
doesn't seem also to be actively looking
to speak to that say Christians he has
kind of been invited to some events and
stuff but he doesn't seem to be actively
looking for that and so why is he doing
it that way
I'd be told me honestly I don't
completely understand I think it might
have
to do with the fact that he wants to
figure this stuff out for himself he
also he doesn't want to be doesn't want
to be tainted doesn't want to be lumped
in a category of people that he finds
doesn't have credibility in terms of the
way that he his experience of of church
and how he felt that people were that
people didn't really believe what they
said and so I think that there's a lot
there there's some personal stuff in
there and that there's also yeah desire
to kind of figure it out but I but I do
think it's it's a little bit of a shame
it let's does she at this point I think
it's a little bit of a shame I wish that
he would kind of talk to more to more
Christians but yeah I don't know I have
no idea
nope all right so Jamie young asks hi
Jonathan and you November QA
you said God is mine got his person got
his infinite consciousness and you come
from the divine mind that caught my
attention because it appears to be a
statement of a metaphysical idealism
which is something I am very interested
in could you expand on this please and
in particular on the personhood of God
is God a person what is a person in your
conception okay so God is not a person I
think that's important to understand I
think that people who say that God is a
person are are theologically extremely
problematic God is a God is a Trinity of
persons God is not a person and so there
is a personal aspect to God but God is
not a person and so what is it person
doing a Kherson the in in in in a
Christian understanding a person is a
high post high
Stathis that is it is an instantiation
of a an essence that's what a person is
now what what has when it has to do with
in terms of saying that what do we mean
like this instant why do we talk about
the instantiation of an essence that is
what christianity insists on is the
reality of the instantiation of of an of
an essence that that is it's not like
platonism that is it's not like you have
let's say in nature and that somehow
that nature
is real in itself so human there's a
human nature that human nature is
somehow you know an ideal form a
platonic form somewhere but rather that
the the essence or the nature is has to
be instantiated it has to be incarnate
it has to be instantiated in in persons
and so that is that is the idea and the
trinity becomes the ultimate version of
that it's like a perfect version of both
of three persons sharing perfectly the
the same essence having all three the
totality of the essence but then also
being completely distinct from each
other and so the notion of trinity is
really this idea of the highest version
of the reality of both the the oneness
and the men enos of the world that those
two are completely united completely
inseparable completely without confusion
okay and so the the so in terms of the
notion of a person that's what it
relates to the idea of the person is is
the hypothesis that is it is the the
particular the particular version of
something okay it is it is an it's an
embodiment of the of the essence and it
to be it's not there's no other way
really those two things the the essence
and the embodiment one reveals the other
you could say it that way and so you
could say that that say Maximus talks
about how you know in the spiritual life
as we start to see the essence it's like
as we start to see the divine sparks or
the the Logie in creation then as we see
the lo you're going to separate
themselves from let's say their
instantiation we notice that no there's
no contradiction that in fact they are
they participate in each they it's not
like they're opposed but rather that one
is the seed of the other like one isn't
is is what is making the other exist but
that that fact means that there's no
there's no there's no contradiction
let's say between all that so that in
terms of in terms of that that's that is
but it's also when I talk about the idea
that God is mine God is infinite
consciousness I think is what I'm trying
to do is to create to try to show the
analogy between ourselves because the
reason why I talked about I talked about
that in the Q&A was because people have
this notion of know when people tell you
something like oh I believe in God but I
believe that God is a force like I
believe that God it's like a law of
nature you know he's an impersonal God
it's like somehow they think that that's
more sophisticated like some other thing
that that's more that that's more
acceptable I don't understand why that
would be more acceptable you know it's
like what why isn't mine an aspect like
why isn't it that that we can see
analogically God through mine since our
mind is how we view the world are we how
we categorize things how we engage with
with with you know how we interpret
things all of that is is mind and so
like why wouldn't I don't understand why
you wouldn't see that
and now that there's an that there's a
there could be an infinite analogy to to
to to mind and so I think that that's
that that's the that's the that was the
point and so we have we have to come
from the the divine mind just like just
like meaning in the world comes you know
is is an interaction between the human
mind and the let's say this potentiality
outside of us just like that so - there
is a there is a metaphysical version of
that there's a met there's a there's a a
a version as to how that becomes an
analogy for the totality of things and
so that's that's the divine that's the
divine mind and that's where name you
know like on earth names come from our
naming things pointing things and
pulling them out of the pulling them out
of the potentiality saying this is a you
know this is I was using examples it's
right there this is a microphone this is
a it's the screen this is a this is a
person this is a color so that's that's
that thing you know there's a there's a
higher level at which that also happens
and that's what makes the that's what
makes the world exist so funny because
last last month I felt like I was being
really Randi and now I feel like I'm
being extremely esoteric and all my
answers alright so sorry if that sorry
if that's what's happening maybe it's
good it's Christmas very soon and we're
gonna plunge into that into the mystery
to the dark the darkness of the solstice
all right so a drew McMahon asks I've
been fascinated with fractals for a
number of years and always felt that
besides just being very cool had a
profound meeting trees mountains stock
market class music everything organic
natural seems to flow follow self
repeating pattern and now listening to
your interpretation of stories and
breakdown of symbolism is revealing the
exact same thing which gives me even
more reason to wonder beside their
ubiquity can you speak to the phenomena
of fractals and if why they're important
so
I think we need likely if we take
fractals at at a homo at a larger sense
like not just necessarily the madman the
mathematical formulas which have
discovered fractals in the the
mathematical world let's say the notion
of fractals is important because it can
it shows us it you know what I talking
about symbolism I talked about how
things are instantiations of themselves
like at a deeper and deeper level and so
that's when you see the the so a very
simple way to a very simple way to
understand it a very simple way that to
understand it and that doesn't even have
to go into too too much complexity is to
understand that all things say you have
one thing so let's say you have what am
I gonna pick up here okay so you have
one piece of paper okay so it's like
that's one that's a one thing now that
one thing is made out of parts right it
has parts it has it has a shape and it's
a color it also has a it's made out of
paper and and you know it's it's it's
made out of different things obviously
this one is only made out of a few
things but like it could be something
more complicated and so but then all
those those parts let's say can also
then be made out of often be made out of
other parts you know and so it's like
things kind of kind of keep keep
becoming smaller and smaller and so it's
like there are parts within part within
parts within parts for the parts then
you can see you but you can still see
the one so I could and then I could put
this this piece of paper in a in a stack
of paper then I could say it's a pad
right and then I could you know and you
could you could you could take this this
pad bind it put it in on a shelf and you
could say that's a library you know and
then you could you could keep going and
so it's like each level follows the same
rule so so as you stop doesn't matter
how high you go you go to being itself
then you start coming down and then at
all the different levels of being you're
going to have something that's one and
it's something that's multiple and it's
just going to keep going again you'll
have these little hierarchies that set
themselves up like right right down to
the smallest possible denominator so
it's like that's just how that's just
how reality works so that's a that's an
example of a of a fractal structure but
it's the same with it's the same with
other other patterns so other patterns
will appear the best patterns they
appear at at macro levels and then they
appeared micro levels and everywhere in
between and so they just kind of just
kind of keep being boxed into each other
I hope that helps all right all right
let's see I think actually ok so here's
another question Laura
Geils asked me I was interested in the
idea of vocation does everyone have a
particular vocation ordained by God Wow
I've always assumed that by uncovering
your gifts as given by God and using
them to further his kingdom that we all
rightly have an option to discover and
follow our calling this does not mean
that everyone does that just that it is
offered for all to pursue also that it
might appear risky to pursue a calling
but perhaps it is riskier not to pursue
a calling varied talents you have
obviously pursued a vocation so I really
value your thoughts on this were you
ever scared did you ever did you did
your experience and Africa change your
ability to take risks ok so there's a
lot of questions in there
[Music]
does everybody have a particular
vocation ordained by God I would say
look I would say I think that the best
way to say it is
this way I would say that everybody has
the vocation to manifest Christ to
manifest the logos to participate in the
logos and to manifest the logos in the
world now what does that mean so it's
going to mean different things for
different people that's for sure and it
is possible to manifest Christ in all
aspects of life now I think that the
difficulty with that type of question is
it's dangerous if it's seen as the way
that it's presented in contemporary
culture you know which is the which is
kind of like the the dreamer version of
that you know like I have a calling you
know like a anything and it's a it's
like this intense thing and I and I and
I think that the intensity of that let's
say I think first of all it can be
delusional sometimes it be very
difficult to to separate your own
passions from that feeling of a calling
so I would be very careful in terms of
that but I do think that that yes it is
it is possible that everybody has a path
that they need to to walk in the world
and that we have to be careful not to
think that all those paths have to be
the same for everyone I think that I
think that the let's say a a holy
warrior like Saint George or st.
Demetrius and a pacifist hermit in in
the you know in the desert those two
things do not have to be seen as
contradiction then they also don't have
to be seen as as being problematic in
their difference
so so so I think that I might be off the
off the subject here but I would say
that you know in turn in my own personal
story I think that every step in in my
life I've done what seemed to be the
right thing at that particular moment
you know and and in the right moments
and the moments that have been that
where I've been the clearest in this is
that in those moments I have trusted God
that I've trusted that if I do the thing
that's in front of me the right thing
that's right there that I have to do
then that will lead me on the right path
and so none of what has happened to me
in the past several years has been
planned by me and when I I'll give you
an example so when I was when I started
carving in 2003 okay I I had a very
strong desire that I that I wanted to
make liturgical arts like a very very
strong desire and and that maybe I could
be make icon carving and that I could do
that for a living
like I I had this this secret prayer you
could say and but at that time
everything in my life was set up
I had just sold my house I was moving to
Africa after seven years like wasn't
seven years at the beginning I was
supposed to be four for three years and
and so here I was it's like I I had the
secret desire inside me which I barely
dared mentioned to anybody
actually I think I never did um and then
but I couldn't I just couldn't and I
what I just did to be honest is I saw
that that's not was in front of me that
just wasn't what was in front of me was
I had set my whole life you know
everything was had been kind of brought
together for me to go to Africa and work
with
since their and so I just said it I just
set that aside in my mind and I I went
to Africa and I we did three years and
we had Eid one year four years in Congo
and then added another three years in
Kenya so seven years in Africa and at
the very last year while I was there in
Africa is when all of a sudden something
appeared on my horizon some opportunity
to to permit me to go back into the icon
carving and so when I saw that appearing
on the road I just I just I just noticed
it and I said okay I just took that and
then I just did a little bit that it was
possible for me to do at the time and
just that little bit and then just kind
of moving forward and and then once I
got back from Africa I wasn't trying to
be an icon Carver I was trying to get a
job I was trying to get regular normal
Joe job but I still had that secret
little prayer inside me saying and I
this is something that I love like this
is something that I think would
integrate my life would integrate my
faith with with my job and it would make
me be able to work close to my family
and all that was there and then it just
it just happened like it just every
little step like there was just this
little opportunity and it happened and
you know it was the same with symbolism
I've been studying symbolism and
studying symbolism since the year 2000
like it's been 18 years that I've been
studying symbolism with with my brother
my tear probably even even a bit before
that but it was always I was just I
there was never an opportunity to talk
about it just because it just wasn't
there so all I did was just keep going
and study and and and keep that in my
heart and I never would have known that
one day I would meet I you know I would
meet this during Pearson fellow and then
he would kind of put me out there on the
scene and and then before I knew it I
was making youtube videos talking about
symbolism like who'd have known and and
all I can do is I can I thank God like I
think
that he's taken me on that path that
he's kind of filled my the longings of
my heart you could say to to be able to
do that but the way that I dealt with it
the whole time is was really just these
little step-by-step pass you know these
little he's just taking one step at a
time and and and just taking what was
given to you and so that that's just
been that's been the way that I've been
and uh in terms of being scared oh yeah
my goodness I'm scared all the time and
and I always know that I'm I always feel
like I'm the Israelites in the desert
you know that's how I feel all the time
it's like it's like ever since I got
back from Africa there's been constant
miracles in my life just crazy miracles
all the time I think I told you guys
this before we we you know we were dirt
poor we got back we had been volunteers
for seven years and we had three we had
two kids my wife was pregnant was gonna
give birth like three months was it two
and a half months after we three months
after we got back from from Africa it
was like you be traveled right on the
like the let the date the limit that
you're even allowed to fly if you're
pregnant and so we got back in June and
she gave birth at the end of August and
it was like crazy coming back to this
house after being gone for seven years
and having two kids and all that was
just was just insane and where was I
going with this
and so and so then we had people sending
us we had I I we had people sending us
money like Frank with people sending us
money I received checks in the mail
three but I never met that I didn't even
know twice three times someone gave us a
car and what one of the times the person
who gave us a car with someone my wife
and met just a week before and she just
said oh I want to give you my car one
time my my my
I had done my tack I was starting to do
the icon carving so I didn't know how to
do like small business taxes so I had an
accountant do my taxes and it was the
first time that I was doing that so I
didn't I couldn't even understand what
he was doing he made a massive mistake
like a massive mistake and the Lex here
the government came after me for like
thousands of dollars in in taxes and so
until I was like I didn't I didn't have
that money I just didn't have that money
and so and I knew that I was I was
living month a month I didn't know how
it was going to resolve itself and a
woman that we know a very prayerful
woman that we know in Congo one day she
just called my wife and she said you
know I've been praying I've been praying
and I just I just feel a conviction that
I need to give you some money
and I have an amount I need to give you
this amount of money and it was just
exactly the amount of money that that I
owed it was like that's that's how much
I could to give back to the government
and so and so all those things have
happened constantly like we would come
back to our house sometimes and there
just be like bags of clothing just on
our porch
and so God is you know but then despite
that despite that all the time I'm
scared
this patreon think you know this patreon
thing happened and I all of a sudden I
saw people like jumping off patreon you
know and like within three days it's
like I'm losing hundreds of dollars like
over Suns like it's just it's just kind
of banishing and I was like oh my
goodness I'm sorry I'm like what's going
on you know what do I do I'm just
panicking and so luckily my wife is very
uh my wife is amazing so I just I go to
my wife and I'm like you know like this
is happening and this is this and and
then and she just looked at me you know
like with this call smiling she's like
Jonathan don't don't worry man don't
worry this is do you think we've never
been here before like we think we've
been here so many times why are you
worried like what and it's like yeah
like why am I worried this is silly it's
just money I mean we're totally fine and
we will be totally fine because this is
what I need to do and and you know
that's it so let's just keep doing it so
so so yeah so definitely I'm scared and
did my experience in Africa change my
ability to take risk that is for sure
hahaha that's for sure
that's for sure one day maybe guys I'll
tell you some stories from Africa like
there are some crazy stories guys with
bullets and yeah and all kinds of stuff
so so so maybe one day I'll tell you
some of the crazy stories from Africa
all right
so Laura Julie asked another question
she said did you like the scrutton jbp
dialogue I did but was wondering if you
had a favorite part um I did I did
really enjoy it I really did I do really
did like it I had to listen to it again
I was listening to all that was carbon
so I I don't think I could identify a
favorite part of mine I was contacted by
the guy who did the who is moderating
the discussion he wrote me an email a
few weeks ago and said you'd like to
press to talk to have a conversation so
so it's interesting we'll see what
happens with that hopefully that will
maybe that will that will bring
something interesting on the horizon all
right guys let's see if we got some
questions in the chat because we're done
with all the patreon questions
okay by the way David Forrest thanks for
making the effort to bringing all those
questions in in the into the chat all
right let's see
Gregory Sandstrom asks how much of what
Peterson says really counts as
scientific
he is vociferous in promoting evolution
as a killer theory there's also a claim
of scientific theology on the other side
I don't know what you mean by a claim of
scientific theology on the other side
but I think that Jordan I think that
Jordan has two aspects to him I think
that he has an extremely analytical
aspect he screaming kind of scientific
analytical aspect but I think that he's
also able to tap in to be more symbolic
kind of mythical structures of things so
that's one of the reasons that's one of
the reasons why he's so interesting is
that he's able to navigate both at the
same time like for example myself I'm
Way more on the symbolic side and way
less on the scientific side and so
although I do understand science in in
its basic forms okay it's not that
complicated you know I'm not versed I
don't I don't read scientific papers I
don't I don't you know I've read very
little actual source material on
scientific things to be honest it
doesn't interest me like I'm just I just
I just find it boring to read scientific
papers so I think that Jordan just like
his own theory about having one foot in
like one foot in order and one foot in
chaos or one foot in order and one foot
in potential I think that just like just
like that he's his own way of living and
his own way of speaking as always kind
of like one foot in a kind of analytical
scientific world and then one foot in a
more that's cuz a symbolic or kind of
mythological world
all right let's see all right I think
we're done with that I think we're done
with the with the question so um so yeah
so I just wanted to a few things like I
before we finish I just want to say that
um this has been a great just crazy
amazing year and I am so grateful for
I'm so grateful for everything I'm
grateful for I'm just grateful for
everything that's happened I'm so
grateful to to to everybody that's been
supporting me and also da just
supporting me in terms of financially
but just all the amazing comments that
people are writing in the comment
sections on YouTube I mean you know like
the comment sections on on the symbolic
world videos I find are they're just so
amazing like so many great ideas in
there and I always feel bad that I'm not
able to get more engaged in the comments
section on YouTube also you know I peek
into the the symbolic world Facebook
group and I just love to see kind of
people engaging there and talking to
each other and discovering similars I'm
talking about matches book and then you
know trying to to push these things
further
um understand it just it just really I'm
really grateful to to everybody's
involved with this and I'm also grateful
definitely grateful to God for just for
yeah just for affirm you know who would
have thought like come on guys like
seriously like who would have thought
three years ago that some of these
things could be possible like some of
these discussions that are going around
whether it's our discussion whether it's
you know these these discussion between
jordan peterson and all these other
people just just the the level of
discussion that the the level of
discussion that's happening is amazing
and also paul van der clay what he's
doing you know his last that one of his
last videos that he did kind of
interpreting the the discussion I had
with rebel wisdom and then other
discussions about during Peterson it was
like oh man I was like Paul you've got
it you're like you're just hitting that
nail just non-stop with what you're
saying and so just exciting to see
people kind of get it and you can just
see that spark you know when people
understand what it is we're talking
about like what is this
this what are these patterns like what
is it that's going on and so so yes I'm
just I'm just extremely grateful and and
I would just say you know for all of you
that are still that that wanna ditch
patreon and you haven't yet I would just
say to just let just pause pause for a
minute and let's see like I'm trying to
get this website up as fast as possible
and so hopefully I mean the the Matthew
on on the anomalous said that he's gonna
try to get it up like before the end of
the month but obviously now is Christmas
and there's a lot of stuff going on so
although I know he really wants to do it
I don't count on him getting there but
um but hopefully by January we'll have a
way for people to support me directly
without without having to go through
patreon and once that starts to happen
then I am actually going to tell people
- to - I'm gonna encourage people to
move off the patreon platform for the
video stuff and and and come to the
website so so just just pay attention to
that also very soon coming soon like in
the next in the next few weeks like I
was hoping that this would be done
already but this patreon thing has
really thrown a big loop at me is I'm
going to this room that you see here
very soon it's that's not what you're
going to see I'm going to I'm going to
make this room into a an actual studio
and so I'm going to I'm actually going
to fix up the walls I'm going to put
some decorations up I'm going to put up
all some foam paneling yet a condenser
mic I'm also getting already got a new
computer and also there's going to be I
might actually even make a carving for
the the background so all that is is
coming so I'm really excited to get that
to happen I just wish it was already
kind of already done but yeah just
everything just got it got crazy so so
yeah and also the same thing this
gremlins video it's it's might land like
on the 24th of December which is which
is which is kind of sad but
yeah we III took so much it just took me
longer to write the script that's oh
it's not it's my fault totally it's not
Thomas's fault so I I'm going to - as
soon as stuff I'm gonna put it up so
maybe it'll be on Christmas Eve
hopefully we on the 23rd but it's not
about Christmas Eve so just to
compensate for that I might make another
video I might tomorrow morning I might
make a video that won't be super edited
but it might be an interpretation of I
want to do an interpretation of a little
Jack Horner and one more Christmas video
about about that
mother Goose rhyme ha ha ha ha so once
again guys just dis thanks for
everything and and yeah so I will I will
see you guys very soon so so having made
Christmas and Christ is born and we'll
talk soon guys bye bye